i i knew a girl used to [ __ ] kyle
dunnigan
by the way he's got a resume like you
wouldn't believe but greatest guy
funniest guy and she said he was so
funny in the dirty talk that it turned
me on
like that's how funny of a guy he is
like he'd be like i'm gonna [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of you and i'm gonna get you
pregnant and then i'm gonna give you an
abortion myself with dirty tools
like [ __ ] like that where you're like
damn that's really funny and and dark
and weird but also captivating wow yeah
he's [ __ ] her ass bill maher he's
like okay people
oh you're not keeping it okay
i don't want a family
okay marriage is stupid
oh you believe in god perfect
oh my god oh sure talk to him uh
anybody not on the patreon is is a
[ __ ] ruby you're missing out folks
i hope uh
dunnigan hears this because uh he's
killing it on on the internet oh his
stuff's so good so good so good next
level comedy we know comics that are
weird enough that we at least know the
eccentric characters to put in the heist
movie yeah like let me call the legion
of skanks we'll knock this out lewis is
the muscle
dave is the brains right right big j is
the uh like he's the talker
he's keeping the morale up right we get
um we get like uh dave attell he's like
the guy smoking a cigarette hits his
last job he's the lookout yeah
that's funny yeah that's a funny movie
to a cast is the heist movie with all
the people you know
[Laughter]
you get michael costa he's the he's the
handsome guy he goes in with a suit he's
like how you doing i'm trying to open a
loan and then they swarm
[Laughter]